when i was in rome i was able to connect
with a franciscan priest who had been an
exorcist for 25 years
and then he permitted me to
sit in on 40 exorcisms that he performed
during the time that i was there and
then that allowed me to learn firsthand
the ministry of the church
for those who were up against the forces
of evil and were seeking help
what was the most extreme one you
witnessed out of the 40 because of
course you get that question all the
time
there are a few that stand out you know
obviously the very first one
you know i'm talking with a uh
an elderly lady and her husband
and she's
explaining to me why she believes that
she's possessed and
you know i i'm just the three of us are
in the room or we're having a
conversation
and i'm watching father carmine the
priest who trained me and he walks into
the room and he puts a roll of paper
towels on the table and he walks back
out and he comes back in and ties a
plastic grocery bag onto the wall
radiator he walks back out again and he
comes in and this time he has a purple
stall which is a piece of purple cloth
that a priest will drape around his neck
as a sign of his priestly office he has
the right of exorcism in his hand and he
immediately takes holy water and he
blesses this little elderly lady as soon
as the drops of water hit her the demon
manifested her eyes rolled in the back
of her head she began foaming at the
mouth growling and snarling and throwing
out all kinds of blasphemies
such as
you know she was insulting god she was
insulting me and
father carmine and just about anyone
basically
doing anything as a way to disrupt this
particular prayer of the church
and then you said so you've seen many so
that was the first one you saw was there
anything that was more extreme than her
absolutely
the one that really stands out the most
was uh during an exorcism when the demon
manifested and the person's body began
to levitate
you saw somebody's body i saw a person
levitate during an exorcism how how much
was it levitation the person rose about
a foot out of the chair they were in
because i'm looking at this in disbelief
and father carmene is praying the right
of the church the prayers and he's
glancing over and looking and he looks
back at his book he looks back at the
person he looks back at his book then he
takes his hand puts it on the head of
the person and pushes them back down
into the chair without ever pausing for
one even one moment
uh in the prayer was any of that caught
on camera the church does not videotape
oftentimes how convenient father but let
me let me ask this question but the
reason the church does that is you
protect the identity of the individual
so obviously at this point you know adam
believes in this stuff a lot i am very
skeptical just to put it out there and
i'd like to see what the audience said
but this mixture of who we have today is
perfect of where i think it's healthy to
be skeptical so you know
if i go to a david copperfield show and
i kind of see you know what the works
he's doing i look up i see the strings
i'm like that's pretty cool how they're
doing it but
in this setting when that happened how
many people were in the room when you
saw this
it was me another priest father carmen a
the individual and a family member that
was with him so five of you five of us
so it's not
so here's the part let's play
let's play a skeptic but let's also play
why would he say this so when you look
at him he doesn't look like something
like i watch his interviews
you know there is what is like yesterday
the biggest thing was what's the motive
like when i watch bob larson i'm not
gonna lie i don't know how you feel
about bob larson you look like you have
some opinions on bob larson or no
we all do okay so i'd be curious to get
your feedback on bob larson
and when i rob larson is who exactly
he's a
famous exorcist do you know who with the
daughters is that yeah bob larson's the
guy with the daughters this is bob
larson so yeah i've seen him a guy like
him
is why nobody would believe in exorcism
okay yeah because this is the part where
it's the flamboyant the showmanship the
you know all the stuff i have a hard
time you may what's your opinion on bob
larson before i even go
further well rather than being critical
of someone else i would tend to be want
to be more positive about what i believe
exorcism is because we talked about
skepticism and exorcist is trained to be
a skeptic
i should be the very last person in the
room to believe that somebody is truly
dealing with extraordinary demonic
activity every other possible
explanation needs to be exhausted and
that's the approach the catholic church
takes that's why even in the united
states we have a protocol that we follow
and step number one of the protocol is
for the person to have a psychiatric
evaluation step two is to have a
physical examination because the church
wants experts in the mental health field
and in the medical sciences to weigh in
on what is happening or what this person
believes is happening in their life
i will say because i am publicly known
as an exorcist
i receive the high volume of people who
reach out to me but the majority of the
people who reach out to me have already
self-diagnosed
and any exorcist will tell you that when
somebody has self-diagnosed
99 percent of the time it's not
something demonic
99 of the time it's not something that's
more like the id or it's something else
that uh absolutely yes okay when someone
self diagnoses meaning they think that
they're possessed by a demon
99 percent of the time they it's not
accurate correct okay so they're they're
calling me and saying i'm possessed that
i need an exorcism and my response would
be
no you're not we may get to that point
yeah but we have to look at what is
actually wrong with them at that point
they're schizophrenic they're bipolar
they're on drugs their depression what's
the what's the it could be all of those
and that's why it has to be
investigated because i would be the
first one to say the church would do
greater harm to uh to someone if she
labels that person as being possessed
and that label prevents the person from
getting the true help that they need so
there may be other people that are
exorcist that may be too quick
to believe
that somebody is possessed but again i
think that would do greater harm if it
prevents them from going and getting
help from
the psychiatrist or their family doctor
because the overriding goal should be to
get
help and for the person who is suffering
whether that be due to spiritual
physical
or mental problems that they're having
in their life so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]